>> Jesse: ROBERT DE NIRO TRIES
TO LINK RANDOM THOUGHTS TO A
SENTENCE.
JOY WAS THERE TO WIND HIM UP.
HE'S PLAYED SOME OF THE MOST
UNREDEEMABLE CHARACTERS.
>> YOU HAVE PLAYED SOME OF THE
REALLY UNREDEEMABLE CHARACTERS.
WAS A PSYCHOPATHIC TAXI DRIVER.
JAKE THAT USED TO BEAT HIS WIFE
IN "THE RAGING BULL," IS TRUMP
WORSE THAN THEY ARE.
>> TO ME, HE IS.
HE HAS NO UNDERSTANDING THAT I
CAN SEE OF THE OUTSIDE WORLD
OTHER THAN ANYTHING AROUND HIM.
HE HAS NO IDEA OF WHAT HIS
PURPOSE IN LIFE IS -- AS THE
PRESIDENT SHOULD BE.
AND THAT IS TO PULL THE COUNTRY
TOGETHER, TO BE FOR THE PEOPLE,
TO HEAL WOUNDS, NOT TO OPEN THEM
UP AND POUR SALT ON THEM.
>> Jesse: DE NIRO CLEARLY HAS
THOUGHTS ABOUT THIS, MORE SON
THAN HIS CAREER.
HIS CHOICE OF ROLLS IS NOW DOWN
TO CINNAMON AND LOBSTER.
HE WAS ASKED ABOUT THE TRUMP
KIDS.
AT LEAST HE DOESN'T WANT MY KIDS
TO TAKE THIS THE WRONG WAY.
>> I DON'T WANT MY KIDS TO TAKE
THIS THE WRONG WAY, BUT IF MY
KIDS DID WHAT THESE KIDS DID, I
WOULDN'T WANT TO BE RELATED TO
THEM.
I WOULD DISOWN THEM.
>>.
>> Jesse: THIS IS SAD.
YOU HAVE SOMEBODY PRETENDING TO
BE A TOUGH GUY TURN OUT TO BE A
SECOND BANANA FOR JOY BEHAR, THE
POSTER CHILD FOR TRUMP
DERANGEMENT.
BOB IS NOW JUST A JIBBERING,
ENFEEBLED ANYONENY SURROUNDED BY
INEPT RELATIVES AS HE FRETS
ABOUT HOW TRUMP IS IN POWER,
HE'S NOT.
TRUMP'S RISE COINCIDES WITH DE
NIRO'S DECLINE.
THE PERSON WHO KNOWS IT THE MOST
IS DE NIRO.
THERE ARE PLENTY OF PRIME WHO
DON'T LIKE TRUMP, BUT DON'T LET
IT WARP THEIR MINDS OR ABILITY
TO SPEAK ALOUD AMONG GROWN-UPS
OR THE VIEW.
BUT THE SCHIFFS AND THE DE NIROS
IN THE WORLD ARE SO EMOTIONALLY
DAMAGED BY POLITICS THEY CAN'T
ASSESS THEIR OWN MOTIONS.
BEING AN ACTOR IS TOUGH, FOR HOW
DOES ONE HANDLE REAL LIFE
WITHOUT A SCRIPT.
YOUR OWN PREDICTIONS ABOUT LIFE
TURN OUT WRONG.
IT'S NOT SUPPOSED TO BE THIS
WAY, DEKNEE THINKS, ONLY THE
COOL GUYS GET TO WIN.
SORRY, BOB.
THAT'S ONLY IN THE MOVIES.
BUT AT LEAST YOU'LL ALWAYS HAVE
JOY.
WHEN DISLIKE IS SO EMOTIONAL,
KATIE, I THINK IT MEANS
SOMETHING ELSE.
HE THOUGHT ABOUT IT.
IT'S IN HIS HEAD.
>> KATIE: IT'S VERY PERSONAL.
ROBERT MUELLER HAD A PERSONAL
SPAT WITH TRUMP.
TO LET IT EAT YOU ALIVE AND LET
IT CONTROL YOUR ENTIRE BEING IS
PATHETIC AND SAD.
IT'S LAZY.
WHEN HI
WHEN HE ATTACKS THE TRUMP KIDS
SAYING HE WOULD DISOWN THEM BUT
NOT SAY WHY.
IVANKA, WENT INTO THE
ADMINISTRATION, GOT RID OF THE
BUSINESS AFTER BEING SUCCESSFUL
AND STARTED THIS GLOBAL WOMEN'S
PROJECT TO ALLOW WOMEN TO GET TO
THE WORKFORCE, SHE'S BEEN ABLE
TO CHANGE THE LAWS IN COUNTRIES
ALLOWING WOMEN TO OWN PROPERTY
MAKING AN IMPACT ON PEOPLE'S
LIVES AND NOW HE'S SAYING IF
THEY WERE HIS CHILDREN, HE WOULD
DISOWN THEM.
HE'S DOING REAL WORK FOR AMERICA
AND AROUND THE WORLD.
THAT'S THE ONLY ARGUMENT THEY
CAN COME UP WITH.
>> JESSE, HE WENT FROM RAGING
BULL TO JOY'S ASSISTANT.
>> Jesse: HE'S SO BORING.
HE'S ALWAYS BEEN BAD AT A LAZY
GUEST.
BUT NOW THE MEDIA HAS FOUND
SOMETHING THAT MAKES HIM
INTERESTING.
THEY'RE DESTROYING IT FOR
RATINGS AND SCORING POLITICAL
POINTS.
IT'S SAD.
YOU CAN SEE IT'S ALL HE HAS.
HE SEEMS A LITTLE OBSESSED.
HE'S A GREAT ACTOR, BUT KIND OF
DESTROYING HIS BRAND A LITTLE
BIT HERE.
I'M NOT SAYING CONSERVATIVES
AREN'T GOING TO WATCH HIS MOVIE,
THEY HAVE.
THIS IS ONE OF THE REASONS WHY
CONSERVATIVES DON'T WATCH THESE
SHOWS.
YOU DON'T WANT TO SEE THE ANGRY
GUY TRY TO TAKE THE PRESIDENT'S
HEAD OFF AND HAVE JOY HELP HIM
OUT DOING THAT AND SELL TV ADS
OFF OF THAT.
IT'S CHEAP AND PEOPLE TUNE OUT.
NOW, TO SAY THAT DONALD TRUMP IS
OUT OF TOUCH WITH THE COUNTRY?
THAT'S CRAZY.
I MEAN, HE'S -- HE'S SOMETIMES
TOO IN TOUCH WITH WHAT'S GOING
ON.
WHAT WE WANT.
HE'S THE MAN -- HE'S GOT THE
FINGER ON THE PULSE.
AND I DON'T THINK HE'S DIVIDED
THE COUNTRY.
I THIS I THE MEDIA HAS DIVIDED
>> Greg: LOOK AT JUAN.
>> Juan: OH, MY GOD, HELP ME,
LORD, HELP ME.
I'M COMING HOME.
>> Greg: TURNING INTO FRED
SANFORD BEFORE OUR EYES.
>> Dana: BE CAREFUL.
I DON'T KNOW CPR.
>> Greg: I DO, JUAN, I'M LOOKING
FORWARD TO TRYING IT.
>> Juan: YOU WANT DANA TO GO
FIRST?
>> Greg: GO FOR IT.
>> Juan: I THOUGHT "THE
IRISHMEN" WAS GOOD.
>> Greg: I DIDN'T LIKE IT.
>> Juan: HE WAS TERRIFIC.
>> Greg: NO, JOE PESCI, GREAT,
JONATHAN MOORE, INCREDIBLE.
HE WAS CRAZY.
CGI SCREWED UP HIS FACE.
>> Juan: OKAY, I HAPPEN TO -- I
AGREE -- THE BODY OF WORK,
EXCELLENT.
>> Greg: YEAH, I MEAN.
>> Juan: EXCELLENT ACTOR.
BUT I'M LISTENING TO YOU ABOUT
THIS ANGRY OLD MAN.
I'M THINKING, THIS WEEK I HEARD
THIS ANGRY OLD MAN GO AFTER THIS
16-YEAR-OLD GIRL AND TALKING
ABOUT NANCY PELOSI.
>> Greg: THAT'S A FUNNY TWEET.
>> Juan: WHEN HE DOES IT, IT'S
FUNNY.
>> Greg: IT'S FUNNY.
>> Juan: DE NIRO DOES IT, YOU
DON'T LIKE IT.
I'M SAYING DE NIRO, YOU'RE RIGHT
TO TALK ABOUT TRUMP.
NOT OKAY TO TALK ABOUT TRUMP,
BUT IT'S OKAY TO TALK ABOUT DE
NIRO.
IT SEEMS TO ME NOBODY GOES
HOLLYWOOD AND SAYS, OH, LET'S
LEAVE THIS ALONE.
IT'S JUST AN ACTOR.
ONLY CONSERVATIVES PAY ATTENTION
TO THESE ACTORS AS ROLE MODELS.
>> Dana: RIGHT, JUST AN ACTOR.
DON'T GET TOO WORKED UP ABOUT
IT, EVERYBODY.
I THINK THERE'S A LITTLE
PROGRESS ON THE CIVILITY FRONT.
THIS IS THE FIRST CLIP WE'VE
SHOWN OF DE NIRO TALKING ABOUT
TRUMP WHERE HE HASN'T USED THE F
WORD.
>> Jesse: I APOLOGIZE.
I TOTALLY MISSED THAT PROGRESS